what is going on everybody welcome to
another python pandas finance and
sentiment analysis tutorial video in the
last video
we basically back tested this strategy
but we haven't visualized the results or
really seen the results at all besides
what the output was per company
my idea is i want to see kind of like a
conglomerate of all of the results and
see you know how do we do with this
strategy
so that's what we're going to do in this
video so first thing i want to do is go
ahead and comment out
this whole bulk here because we're not
going to run it again
so we'll just do three quotes there
three quotes there
and it's interesting because
this sorcery right here look at this or
if i wonder if this happens for all of
y'all
it's like says it's just such a long
list i guess
i'm really fast at typing anyway
um we'll come down here and what we're
going to want to do is visualize the
results somehow
and so the best way that we can do that
is we can reference the data that we
just output
and i just want to put them all together
we could plot up literally every single
stock
and see the performance of all of the
companies and
i suppose i could we could do that as
well
and maybe we will but mostly what i want
to do is actually have just a single
line of the performance
and so what i'm going to go ahead and do
is we're going to say define
results and here we're going to say
df for date frame is going to be pd.read
underscore csv
and the csv that we just created was
performance
underscore data underscore sp 500 ish
dot
c s v comma the index
uh column is
time and finally parse
dates equals true because we do
uh want to parse the date information
next
since we're parsing dates the other
thing we're going to want to do is we're
going to do df.sort
underscore index and in place
true and what this does is kind of what
we've already
seen it do in one of the other videos is
just orders by date and the reason why
we want to do this
is the data currently looks like this
where we have the date stamp time the
stock and then each
time we go over whether the company
stock ticker anyway
um each company we go through it
alphabetically basically
and then of each letter in the alphabet
basically or each
one alphabetically that we go through
then we go through the date so
basically it goes start to end per stock
so we got a aaa
apple and so on all the way to the
bottom so this entire document is
actually not ordered by data it's
ordered alphabetically first
then you know the primary ordering is
alphabetical
then the secondary ordering is by date
so first we want to actually order by
date
so we can do what we're hoping to do
here
so now let's say df.store by index or
yeah sort of index and place true
now we're going to do is we want to mesh
all of this stuff together
we want to basically make an average of
all of this stuff
and so the way that we're going to do
that is i wish there was a better way to
do it i'm not really sure the best way
to do it
and what we're going to do is use
panda's expanding mean
so what this does is at every step of
the way it does an entire
average basically of the data
and so like with a moving average that
would give us like a let's say a 20
moving average it would only be an
average of the last 20 plots when really
we want to know the performance average
of this strategy period
uh and so that's like an ongoing thing
so from start to finish what is our
performance
and so that'll give us a decent
representation of what our portfolio
would look like
if we invested into this kind of
strategy so
what we're going to do is we're going to
say df and we're going to make a new
column and it's going to
be x mean for expanding mean
um and what we're going to do is say
that equals pd.expanding underscore mean
this is something built into pandas what
do we want to do this operation on we're
going to do this operation
on df pc which is percent change right
because we've normalized all this data
into a percentage change
and then um the next one is
minimum elements right so we're just
going to say zero there's no minimum
that we're going to
you know start with and that's really it
now what we can do is we can do
return df
x mean and now what this is going to do
is going to return a data frame
of x mean and basically it's just going
to give us the index of date
and the x mean so or the expanding mean
so we'll have date and that so now we
can actually plot it
so we come down here and what we can do
is res for results equals results
and then res.plot and we'll say
label equals i don't know
uh holistic performance
and then we're going to do plt.ax
actually i suppose we could have this
here
x line 0 color
equals k and a line
with equals four and basically let's
just make a horizontal line
on the zero mark and so if we plotted
you know each stock one by one this
would make a lot more sense
so we could clearly see the zero
you know profit line basically um
and so maybe we'll use that for now
we'll just have it there anyways and
then plt
legendary plt dot show
now um that should be good
it might take us a second so i guess
we'll go ahead and save
and run it hopefully we don't have any
errors as well oh you know what
here we have to do one more thing sorry
i hit ctrl c to
uh cancel that one from running what we
have to do is we have to come over to
our data see we said we wanted to index
by time
that's not going to work and we wanted
to index by pc that's not going to work
because if we look at our data set um
the first column actually has none of
that okay so
what we need to do is we're going to
have oops uh we'll just
add this first row ourselves so hit
enter there do time
uh stock i suppose
and then we had time stock price
pc okay that should work for us time
stop
let's see time stock
actually you know what i think that was
actually funds right that wasn't the
stock price
right so actually not price that's funds
funds and then pc for percent change
so um now we've got the column title so
we'll save that let me close this
let's run that one more time and now
this time hopefully we
will have a result um that would have
gotten very angry with us had we
continued on
so uh so this should just be like a
single line and we can see what kind of
performance we're seeing already
and because obviously our hopes aren't
too high because our strategy
is literally this here is mine anyways
it plotted up
so this is our performance overall or on
average basically so if we had a
portfolio that was comprised solely of
this strategy
this is kind of what we uh could expect
to see
so initially we have a little bit of
volatility here
i'm going to go ahead and say that
that's well i guess we're not we didn't
start until jan
13. but
i'm not sure though i think that by
i can't remember what i said in the
initial when that when the rest of the s
p 500 comes on board
but i'm guessing that's what happens
here is we have okay all of the other s
p 500 stocks
because initially we only did like three
companies and then we kind of branched
out to 12
then we did like 115 maybe and then
finally i just said okay let's do the
entire s p 500
so anyway actually not too bad we have a
little bit of drawdown here
and then you know here then we have this
massive spike here
and then from actually really this point
onward
uh pretty flat linear line okay so
um not bad the return here is pretty
pretty poor uh probably not even beating
inflation with a five percent
increase so definitely not happy
about that you're definitely not beating
the market in this scenario
either i mean from jan 13 all the way to
now
we're probably like i don't know 50 60
if not more we could look but of the s p
500 returns but
anyway uh at least we're not in the
negatives and we think we might be on to
something or at least
the strategy is somewhat accurate but
you can't really make that judgment you
would have to
i suppose basically it from this point
onward you could start to make some sort
of judgment like that just simply
because
we don't have any draw down and you know
the s p 500
definitely has draw down points at
various points along this way
so it's nice to see that we don't have
the same drawdown points but
the question is can we modify this a
little bit to
see some better results because really i
mean just because we have a little bit
of drawdown with the s p 500 say you buy
this spy
you're going to choose to do that versus
this five percent over a whole year
so a few things we have to consider as
well one we're not paying trade costs
still so this is not including any sort
of trade
you know costs so if this is a high
frequency trading as in we're doing like
you know multiple trades a day um
now we're kind of gonna probably be in
trouble and would maybe make ourselves
in the negatives depending
so we still have to kind of factor
something like that in how many trades
are we making
but also the question is can we modify
this strategy at all
to improve our
return so if we want to modify the
strategy we'd have to rerun this
this data
well i've commented it out but we'd have
to rerun you know this and it exists it
just doesn't want to show it to us
so we have to rerun it and so the answer
to that though
is yeah so if you like we're for example
here
there's a lot more um there's a lot more
positions we could make so here we're
actually only entering into
about i don't know this this covers
less than half of the possible positions
that we
could take into account so the first
thing you'd want to do is really
add to this to make it to where you're
more willing to enter into positions
now that's going to also increase your
trade frequency so we still want to know
like what is our actual trade frequency
here but um we're missing a lot of
positioning
for sure as far as you know when we'll
buy and sell we could also change how
much
we buy and sell at but also most
importantly what we're missing here
is any sort of relation to where the
market is at the moment so
i mean and also what's the actual
overall sentiment
so in the market it might make more
sense to just buy the companies that are
just have positive sentiment and stay
away from the ones that don't
or if you're going to buy into a
company's trend maybe buy the one that
has
somewhat positive sentiment because
we're fairly confident it's going to
keep going up because sentiment is very
positive
you could also flip that and you know be
more of a value investor and only buy
companies where their sentiment is the
weakest or something
so there's definitely a lot of other
strategies to look into and then also
my biggest thing though is that we have
to kind of
we need to be able to look at what the
price is at the moment and because
like i said before sometimes price goes
up and sentiment goes up because price
went up and then we're finding ourselves
buying at the high and selling at the
low
so that's not good at least from what we
see we're not doing that the majority of
the time but it
probably would be in our best interest
to eliminate that and
um and then maybe add some more
strategies to so
if you add a few more strides to this i
imagine that we could probably improve
this
quite a bit so maybe we'll add a few
more position entering
parameters just to see so that's
probably the easiest addition that we
can make to this script
but then after that we probably moving
forward since we're kind of happy with
what we saw there
we need to incorporate trade costs and
actually probably i should incorporate
we'll
incorporate trade costs before we add
any more parameters because the addition
of parameters is
can only really increase the trade
counts so uh
so we'll go ahead and do that too so
we'll add the trade costs
into this um and then we'll probably
have to regenerate a new
new uh output dump but that's okay so
anyways
that's what we have to look forward to
if you guys have any questions or
comments uh regarding
everything up to this point go ahead and
leave those below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions
until next time